you know the Jerry Seinfeld the Seinfeld
episode where Man Hands where the woman
has that big and so everybody would say
that's toughy because my hands were
really big I stopped growing in the
fourth grade like I've always I've been
this height since I was nine I got my
period nose iron yeah wow in a swamp on
a field trip yeah unbelievable but I
thought but everybody in my family gets
it really really early but I had my
American Girl book so it was fine like I
was prepared you knew I knew what to do
and then um what's an American Girl book
The American Girl book the body the body
book well I have three girls were up
here so he explains okay yes you're
talking about there's a declaration of
independence
and then there's the American Girl book
thank you to our sponsor ZocDoc ZocDoc
is the only free app that lets you find
and book doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance are
available when you need them and treat
almost every condition Under the Sun go
to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's
z-o-c-d-o-c.com trash
zocdoc.com trash this show is sponsored
by betterhelp it's so easy to get caught
up in what everyone else needs from you
and never take a moment to think about
what you need for yourself therapy can
give you the tools to find more balance
in your life so you can keep supporting
others without leaving yourself behind
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday you guys
life's more exciting when there are
peaches involved and that's why we're
brought to you by simply spiked Peach go
to
drinksimplyspiked.com trash Tuesday to
find out how to get your hands on new
simply Spike Peach that's drink simply
spiked.com trash Tuesday this is
flavored beer naturally flavored with
other natural flavors simply Spike Co
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply spike is a trademark
of the Simply Orange Juice company you
guys are rising prices stressing you out
if you're looking for ways to cut costs
you need rocket money
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday hello
sluggies
um welcome to this episode of trash
Tuesday and also I am here on the set of
Annie wood my new solo podcast we have
20 episodes down we've had amazing
guests it's been so fun the show is
growing it's special it's Unique and I
think you guys will like it so check it
out if you haven't already it's every
Thursday at 9 00 a.m Pacific Time noon
Eastern we love you so come see us you
can also see me live
I'll be in Raleigh North Carolina May
12th and 13th if you came out to my
shows in Greensboro you're going to want
to come to Raleigh too it's going to be
a different vibe those were wild ones
I'll be in Baltimore at Magooby's June
2nd and 3rd I'll be in Salt Lake City
Utah Wise Guys Club June 9th and 10th
and then I'll be in Calgary with the
Great Outdoors Comedy Festival with
Andrew Schultz August 27th a lot more
dates are being added so go to
annieleterman.com shows enjoy the show
hi slugs I am on tour I'm going to be in
Boston New York City Atlanta and Raleigh
you can get tickets at Esther onice.com
I've been here in New York working on my
standup I cannot wait to have fun with
you guys at these shows I will see you
get tickets at Esther onice.com
foreign
I learned when I came here yet okay so
the American Girl Corporation I'm losing
my mind had the wherewithal to give us
this American Girl book that also they
use The Branding of the dolls that we
know and love and then they taught us
about our bodies your boobs growing
pubic hair it basically taught you about
like the it's called the care and
keeping of you
and it is so cute and on the cover it's
like three girls
um from different races and nothing to
say I think it's an Asian girl blonde
girl and a black girl right I think so
and they're they have they're like 12
and they have like the towels around
them and they have like a towel on their
head like they just got out of the
shower and then you open the book and
it's like your body's Gonna Change and
it's so exciting you know and then it
tells you like this is where tampon goes
illustration it was incredible I owe my
life to America I was an American girl I
am an American girl you know what I mean
but I and I remember going through it
with my mom it created comfortable
conversations I loved it that is so
sweet my only
um my only knowledge about periods when
I was younger is because I was an
athlete my mom constantly breathing down
my neck like you're gonna peek when you
get your period don't get your period
you're gonna peek so when I finally got
my period And I was like 13 or 14. I
remember just crying my little heart out
I'm like it's over for me I've pee this
is it my athleticism period that's what
happened rest in peace baby I love you
that's what happened wow so they did
this for you guys there is anything
available to be fair I didn't have it I
saw it at a friend's house so uh nobody
really took the time to get it for me
but sounds like maybe your mommy loved
you my my mother got me a driving
instructor and the care and keeping of
you because she didn't want to
do it yeah you know what I mean like I
think like that that's not at the same
time I wasn't driving at nine and I
didn't get my period at 16. you know I
mean but I think um there was just
things that she
felt like the book and somebody else
could do better and then if I had
questions but my mom was also somebody
who's like super scientific so I asked
her
to the point where it would turn you off
from it she's so smart I would say like
Mommy how are babies man she goes when
the sperm enters the Egg and I go oh
what the I thought it was sex
you know what I mean so she would always
answer honestly but I just think that
like whole hand-holding thing she didn't
want to do it you know I like
that that's busy she had things she
interested in other people and I think
it worked out really well you know so
like when I got my period I was like I
need a tampon and Mrs Campos is
like what'd you say I'm like a tampon
a regular please a stat you know like I
knew what to do or whatever but I um
what why would he talk talk about this
do you think someone that always knew
what to do have that energy I know
unfortunately I learned the hard way
which is I failed or embarrassed myself
terribly and then I learned what to do
if you need to I still don't know where
the dental card is for your health
insurance I can't find it on the website
that's one thing that I like I don't
think anyone knows where that is I just
go to I know that I pay for it and I let
them pull up my records of the dentist
I'm like look is it real I I don't think
they have the physical cards anymore
it's it's a scam maybe you get two teeth
cleanings a year but there's fine print
of course I do I am of the very lucky
few select people in this world that
gets to be a mutual friend with Tuffy on
Tick Tock oh my God I was like what and
so I get to randomly see when I scroll
my my fyp these videos from her that are
like Hey we're all feeling kind of like
my friends only posts her friend's only
posts are like
they've given me so much confidence
motivation like do you know that that
the life you you juice and pump into
that app I saw a bunch of people posting
about like are people's views down oh
like I don't want to do this anymore and
I'm like like there's a and I'm like
don't stop doing it because the
views are down who gives a about
views you know what I mean like so I
just was like you know I follow you
because I like you so maybe somebody
just needs to
there's so many videos sometimes that
like
um that get like minimal views I think
like my mom and her assistant launch and
they're like ah and then they close
their phone and I'll be on the street
and some somebody will be like that
video you did was so funny and I'm like
right and you think no one saw it and
it's not true so like I think the
problem with like social media too is
that especially platforms like Tick Tock
incredible Tick Tock takes care of their
creators in so many ways but you can get
a video that gets I mean we've all had
it it gets 5 million views and then the
next one is like four yeah you know what
I mean and it's that mean girl group
chat that you're in without knowing it's
like all four of them be like loser lose
or you know what I mean like I know I'm
in those I know I'm in those I know I'm
in the wait I thought I was the only one
that daydreamed and fantasized about all
the people talking about me in a
group but you probably fantasize about
when you're like using your vibrator
like you're just like yeah you
hate her if you we were just talking
about this on the last episode of Rick
Glassman like I do I'm anti-vibe
anti-vibrator she's a I am she's trying
to lower her Baseline tolerance to get
off yeah so like I last night Taffy I'm
telling you under six seconds
really touched my own with my own
hands I'm like well and I was there done
easy peasy rolled over went to bed then
what's the point of anything if you're
not doing that what's the point the Lord
the lord gave it to you
you know what I mean like come on are
you have you watched um pen 15 well
favorite
it's like looking in a mirror when I
want a show when she starts
humping that pillow I'm like I was I was
the family Pomeranian
absolutely I didn't hump things I made
things hump each other oh yeah and so
like my dolls would like Barbie yeah you
know and you don't you don't understand
it's so crazy because I don't think I
understood truly what sex was until I
was
still maybe but I feel like I had to be
like I had to be like 13 14 for me like
really wrap my mind around like what if
you think about it it's very disgusting
it's so and it's so we when you learn
what it is you're like it's that
and then you're doing it and you're like
this rocks
but I I feel like uh for the the vagina
we call it a panini press yeah I caught
a badge I called it naan bread oh that's
so sweet not as cute Don is a cute one
your vagina I think uh
I think it's like such a it's such a
gift you know what I mean and like to
not take advantage of her you know what
I mean come on anti-vibe don't be
anti-you but she's saying so she you're
saying that I could still have like
maximum joy that is more than the
maximum Joy I feel for myself alone I
think listen I've I've talked to my
friends about this too
I I'm any I come in like two seconds you
don't have to be you have to do a lot oh
external internal but you don't you
boy
and then you're saying external internal
that's crazy oh yeah whatever three
different ways yeah I just think about a
listen my PornHub search history is a
couple who loves each other I don't need
a lot all right I don't need a lot
that's what I said so there's a porn
star I think that you would Love
Actually I don't watch a lot of porn
please like how do you know she would
love it because
well because I heard the last episode
and I was like oh you know what I mean
well a Nazi yeah I can I have to have
you say it first but I was like I was
like thinking about it today and I was I
heard that this morning and I was like
oh there's this one dude that I saw
somebody tweet about years ago
and they were like does anybody watch
Owen gray do you know oh yes of course
thank you yeah so I searched him and
there's all these like actors or
whatever I'm like okay I gotta go to the
hub I I never go to the hub I can use my
old Noggin all right I'm a creative
and so I was like let me go to the
hub and I search Owen gray it's this guy
he's tall he looks dead he's so skinny
covered in tattoos he makes eye contact
with these girls and holds their heads
and his dick is the size of my arm and
he is like does that feel good do you
like that
that's CR I had to turn it off because I
answered enough because it it's what the
she thinks is happening with the
vibrator I will never enjoy sex again if
I keep watching him what she thinks is
happening with the vibrator is if what
would happen if I kept watching Owen
gray it would it would take the joy out
of it ah it's called right to you now
just from you reenacting what that is
wait the last the last guy that I was
with he used to call him intimacy boners
where he would get blood flow if I would
be affectionate or vulnerable or
vulnerable he would be like blood flow
blood flow and he'd call him intimacy
boner oh my God but that means was it
how
what was his childhood like
sexual trauma oh my wait really or like
nobody ever showed him kindness uh maybe
right I have that column number again
well I have like my I didn't no one met
my emotional needs so like if someone is
you're engaged though yes yeah now yeah
okay but as a child like if someone
nobody talks Dave will often be like
you're like a little girl who no one
spoke to like that's the energy I bring
to the table so I'm like talk to me look
at me hi come play but you don't like
being held
a lot of people don't it's you know what
it is it's being held is so hypersexual
to me oh really like hand-holding or any
kind of physical time like if I laugh
and I like grab your wrist like I do
that a lot like I want to Pat me too
yeah and something's embarrassing I have
to talk about that but like the touch is
so sensitive to you it's so much that
like when I moved to LA and people just
casually were hugging each other left
and right I was like whoa I can't that's
like too much for me but I I like it too
much almost like I need it so I can't is
that does anyone follow I eat no yeah
like you yearn for it but it's something
that also makes you uncomfortable it
only makes sense to me coming from an
intimate partner really yes I think
touches I you know I grew up in like a
multi-generational household so it's
like you almost like have to be okay
with a certain level of like people
around you and touching yeah we don't
have personal views in my house either
yeah like so it's disposable for me so
like when I touch somebody like it could
be misconstrued as I think we had I had
a huge argument with a comic once
because he was like well when you first
met me you were like very flirtatious I
was like oh my God and I said I wish I
was young a hug and I had fake titties
at that time I had they I don't have
them anymore but he was like yeah you
pressed your boobs again
I okay yeah like fisted yeah taggy
activated oh my God
because when I moved to New York so in
Miami from the time you're in elementary
school when you see your friends you
give them a kiss on the cheek like what
it could be a class of 32 guess how many
kisses you're giving out the point one
if you don't like somebody you skip them
and it's beef it's a big deal so
like I even even like a week ago I saw
this that I can't stand
and I and I and she she's a
weirdo but my friend was like you have
to say hello to her I'm like I'm then
I'm not doing the sound I'll go and
that's also me but to that point so when
I moved to New York and people were like
did you flirt with my boyfriend I'm like
what are you talking about they're like
you kissed him hello and I said
I acknowledge nobody wants your man
nobody wants your man you too can
go enjoy J crew together you know what I
mean like please please nobody wants
your man I acknowledge his
existence and you should be
grateful because okay oh no she likes
Brian I've never liked to Brian you're
good you're good bro you know what I
mean what is a name that will get you
going
a name like an enemy's name no like if
you don't you don't want to a Brian
you want to uh
an Alex uh Jason well Jason Momoa what's
up I uh a name that I like Spanish names
I like Spanish names I like like
Santiago rosanti is such a fat boy
obvious is a super hot boy um it's sick
sick butted name thick butted baseball
butt I love baseball body oh my God
baseball players are the hottest of all
they have sometimes a little belly I
love a belly on a man
when I see men like working I'm like
don't go too hard
let's keep I called the Bell let's keep
the bell ringing agree all right we need
a good old belly on that have you ever
been with a a
chubby boy like a real chubby boy yeah
the big gut oh when they have sex with
you their belly hits your foot so I know
this is last range thing to say but my
ex is a five foot four Korean man with a
big belly
he used to make me come really fast
because his belly would hit my clip I
love that belly the belly does
things for me that I can't even explain
to you with my exes I used to stand
behind them and they're like they're
probably gonna hear this and be like I'm
chubby you're a chubby mother I was
standing behind them and walk behind
them like prom pose just on there it's
on the belly I've been with
Fitness dudes too
you're working out on vacation
getting together or I did one guy that
only ate boiled chicken oh I've and
broccoli and you yeah that's the one oh
sick you're farting rock and roll two we
can't do anything fun I think
the final straw for me was we went to
like a really nice restaurant in the
city I forget where it was the word
Gotham is coming up for me but I don't
remember it's something a really nice
restaurant beautiful chandel like a real
I call it like a real New York night you
know what I mean like it's a
like you go to the bar with your friends
you go to this nice restaurant maybe
later you'll do karaoke like we were
having a New York night we go to this
like restaurant that I've always wanted
to go to like this was like 10 years ago
maybe and he brought his food
I rather
I'd rather out of Pinecone than
have you then hear the sound of the
plastic container opening oh it was
multi-tiered oh my God no it was like
the it was like a Chinese food
takeout the Box the box but you know
what I bring a thermos too with his uh
pre-workout you guys so just ice water
is fun lemon extra lemon please do we
need to send love though because that's
full eating disorder no he has a native
disorder that is like sad and I feel bad
I'm not sad but it is such a turn I'm
not sending him love because great
because the other day this guy but
but yeah those dudes and you know
what they're angry when you are just in
full you know when you're fully
ketoacidic and you're just subsisting on
broccoli and chicken you're angry I had
no idea that keto made your smell
it also makes your breath smell I had no
idea so I bought a keto book and one of
the people I was working I was working
in an office and my co-worker was like
girl don't I had a key to I just bought
one and it was on my desk and I was like
in a zoom and when I AI or Skype this is
pre-covered so who knows what I
was doing we saw each other's faces and
then um I closed I closed the laptop she
was like I saw you got a keto book and I
was like yeah she's like don't
do it my friend did it and she said
smell like rotten meat
you guys it's really difficult find
a doctor
even more so to find a doctor that you
trust someone who has a good bedside
manner someone who you feel absolutely
safe with and if you've been stewing
about a health problem you've had ZocDoc
is the answer ZocDoc is the only free
app that lets you find and book doctors
who are patient reviewed take your
insurance and are available when you
need them and treat almost every
condition Under the Sun I'm telling you
guys like if you need a dermatologist an
OB GYN if you have an ear infection
anything at all ZocDoc has it
um no more Dr roulette or scouring the
internet for questionable reviews with
ZocDoc you have a trusted guide to
connect you to your favorite doctor you
haven't met yet millions of people use
zocdocs free app to find and book a
doctor in their neighborhood who is
patient reviewed and fits their needs
and scheduled just right go to
zocdoc.com trash and download the ZocDoc
app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com trash zocdoc.com trash
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
therapy can give you the tools to find
more balance in your life so you can
keep supporting others without leaving
yourself behind therapy has been an
indispensable part of my life what I
like about betterhelp 2 is they have a
journal feature so in between my
appointments with my therapist if I'm
having heavy thoughts that day but it's
let's suppose it's five days before my
next appointment I'm able to write these
thoughts in my journal and I can discuss
them with my therapists on the date of
my appointment if you're thinking of
starting therapy give betterhelp a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help.com trash Tuesday
like even in school too yeah it's so hot
but it's it's almost like if you smell
anybody on even like like dka which is
diabetic keto
there is a scent there like I can't
imagine like it's Floral in a floral
right what's in the box it's this kind
of floral rot oh when you have to when
you know you have to throw away your
roses yeah but then you like if
something in your trash is really bad
but you're someone is coming and you
don't have time to throw your trash you
just light a candle
like and it's a floral candle so it's
the combination of like oh you now have
just floral around somebody
said what did Tuffy's smell like
and they said you know when you know
something in your garbage I would
die die oh my God I'm gonna pop an extra
probiotic when I get ah
because I I got in I got swept by the
whole Atkins crease which is just about
the same as keto right keto is just
rebranded it's like red butter and
prayer yeah I can't say that my
was in its prime you know in my we were
Prime puss I mean we weren't we were not
not even mid no no I don't believe I I
know the science is saying what it's you
know the science is there I just don't
believe I don't believe in
smelling bad ever I I just that's my
political investor but have you done it
BV is BV there's a reason you have no
you have a nose and there's a reason why
your nose takes and smells it's supposed
to inform you about the world around you
it's supposed to inform you about
disease X Y and Z so if you have an
overgrowth of bacteria in your vagina
you should be able to say hey something
is wrong I'm not gonna be like something
I want to ride yeah you know who else
says I know the size is there but I
don't believe it Evangelical Christians
oh okay
I won't even say with that for a second
don't be an eve don't be the Evangelical
foreign
I've had bad you know my shit's gone bad
only a few weeks ago I told you I was
like look the BCC I don't know what I
don't know if it's a BCC but something
is wrong we gotta used to call and then
it was because I used um an old old like
I had just dusted off like I found old
Lube that I was like okay please don't
use Loop that you have to blow like a
library book like a face Master well our
our
um Annie who is the third girl on our
show couldn't be here she basically says
like you can't have rollover Loop no cat
used Lube from they're not in it and I
think that's what I was cursed with I
used it from an old relationship with a
new boy and God struck me down he said
silly goose uh-huh oh my God no I
sometimes I do
like I have it I had I when I was
younger my anxiety was way worse you
know what I mean uh because the idea
that my body like the Osmosis Jones that
like the idea that when I went to sleep
that my body continued to like my heart
would be without my permission or my
um supervision
freaks me the out so I would have
these panic attacks because I'll try to
control my heart rate and I figured out
that I couldn't so like the the vagina
sorry the technical term the vagina
um when figuring out that it has like a
minor or like the gut brain even that
like this is all these are all little
neighborhoods and they all have their
own HOAs literally it drives me
nuts it drives me nut do not
like that you don't have control over it
I like that it's not existing on its own
I feel like if I was in control I could
I could do a stellar job and I could do
so much better than this doing right now
you're reminding me of one of my biggest
anxieties which is like you know
swallowing so I'm like this is something
that has did we all swallow my whole
life no but you can't do that after I
think the third or fourth time you
cannot make yourself swallow because
swallowing is like a natural thing or
it's a it's like a reflex basically just
like breathing is right but that's why
when in my late 20s I was these extreme
panic attacks and they would focus on
your breath kalila I'm like no that is
the source my breath is a source of my
anxiety because I don't trust it to do
its thing like I don't trust it to be
some like autonomic like you know thing
that my body does on its own I have to
supervise it like you said so then I
would like just be so like hyper
Vigilant about my breathing so when I
had to learn to meditate it had you
couldn't say the word meditation changed
my life can you meditation is the best
thing in the entire piece you
speak on that sell it to me what do you
do well how long because are you going
for like five minutes an hour the
longest I've done is two hours wow are
you silent are you listening to
something
um
so when I first and people say like I
could never i'm like if I can
please I'm like the road runner up and
no I yeah this is Gothica this is Jim
Carrey 23. like we're good I I think
there was just a point where spiritually
I was in a lost place and the idea of
like downloading information was very
or like not even downloading information
but like really hearing myself or like
you can ask yourself a question and you
talk back it's crazy but like to get to
that point I would sit with myself and I
I would listen to my breath and then I
think a lot of people think that it's
thinking of nothing
and and but then somebody told me you if
you have a thought you bring it in you
look at it because if you ignored it's
just going to come knocking I look at it
and then I acknowledge it and then I put
it away
but I imagine the white room that
Squidward is running through you know
what I mean SpongeBob reference thank
you guess my dick hard same that's an
intimacy yeah that's the connection but
um once I was like in that place where I
was like oh I can welcome those thoughts
or whatever
I started doing guided ones on Gaia and
YouTube and there's another calm I don't
whatever but I started doing those and
it started with like 10 minutes
and then after the meditation I would
like Journal about the things that I
thought about or I would start the
meditation with like I would look up
guided meditation fear guided meditation
resentment there's one meditation that I
talk about all the time it's about
resentment
that um you you go into your childhood
home
or your childhood room
and if you walk into that room and it's
not your room and it looks like
something else that means something
right and I would go to my childhood
room and it would be like concrete you
know I grew up in a in a golf course
town a lot of greenery a lot of Golden
Retrievers so I was like that's really
weird but then um on the table there's a
table in the room and there's a teddy
bear on it and the teddy bear represents
all the people who have hurt you
disappointed you
and you have to go up to it and you hug
it and you have to say thank you thank
you so much put down the teddy bear and
you walk out the room if you cannot walk
out the room with the teddy bear
attached to you you've made resentment
part of your personality
and that was the first one that I was
like this is doing something for me
because I because I can I lie my ass off
in therapy
like I want to get into that let's talk
about it doesn't know me at all
you know that has been the biggest
barrier for me because I still no matter
what I there is still an element of
people pleasing oh then yes so even to
her I still want to be respectful I want
to be liked by my therapist so that is
something like I've been in therapy
since I was 15 years old and I think
that I've never fully until recently
been just the truly ratchet that I
am as my therapist and I want to get
there and I'm slowly starting to get
there but there is this fear that shame
yeah it's a lot of shame that she's not
going to be on my side or you know like
it and Doc we had Dr Duran um a couple
episodes ago and he was like the big you
are wasting your money you are only
doing a disservice to yourself and I'm
like but it's so hard
learning about yourself at the same time
doctor yeah why why do you lied to why
would you lie to a therapist I mean I
feel like there's something I feel like
shame is a sign you know what I mean
shame is a sign of that I know better
I know better and so I feel like in my
mind I'm like I know better and I know
why I did that you know what I mean like
I don't wanna there are some things
about my I think I just want to say the
word Theresa to me there
and also there's a part of wanting to be
the favorite wanting to be the best not
and and being like um and being someone
who
um oh the best student I'm absorbing it
I'm getting better and also part of me
is like I want her to feel like she's a
good therapist it's the same oh my God
she is I'm just not giving her thank you
for saying that like I feel like I
haven't been able to articulate dating
did you learn that in therapy
that is so validating thank you for
saying I'm like you are
I hate when people of therapy talk me
and that's the only jargon they use
especially when we're in a full-blown
fight and they'll say things like I'm
gonna take a beat to all that deaf
emotion I'm like oh I'm about to it
oh I know because I locked the door
where are you gonna go babe I hate her
when I'm in a conversation with someone
I'm like I just feel like your therapist
told you to say that like I'm like
be you you little the word
gaslighting on Tick Tock is going to
make me shave my head it's oh but that's
all like just even the
pseudo-spirituality that has just seemed
to like the all of tick tock is riddled
with pseudo-spirituality where people
are supposed to be more enlightened
supposed to be all still awake and this
and that but they're all just
monsters man I'm like really truly you
found yourself a toughy top five female
pop stars of all time Warriors pop stars
yeah
Brittany James Spears thank you that was
the right first answer
Abba oh she's good she knows what she's
doing she knows what she's doing
I'll say for me Gaga is in that is on
the top five at Gaga's five number five
okay that's out of like every like that
yeah you know I'm also putting Madonna
in my top internet Jackson that's it oh
yeah Janet Jackson we're not throwing
like a Cher in there I don't consider
share Pop I consider her
um a doctor
philosopher exactly I I don't I wouldn't
consider her as a cop I would consider
share as somebody who studied as like
within folk and then like power ballads
and like disco and then from that she
went into like
she's done it everything you
could say share could be country even
right the ability that you have to
articulate shares discography I love her
so much I that is I I love you for that
today somebody asked me if you saw of
someone and who would you lose your mind
like who would you be Starstruck for and
I said Michelle Yvonne Robinson Obama
yeah and
um and Stevie Nicks but I don't think I
could handle share I think
I think I would hold her by the wrist
and not realize I'm doing you know like
I have something and like not realize it
you know I just saw this clip of her
basically it was like an old clip I
think it entered like oh why she didn't
like Madonna she's just like I just
don't think she's a good person oh she
was mean at this party yeah I hate the
sheriff versus Madonna she was at Elton
John not an Elton John party whose party
was she at that she was rude too
was it a Freddie Mercury party
how could he not like but my things I
just said have you seen
when Sonny died they'd already broken up
yeah right and he had his he had a wife
and children and and Cher met him when
she was 16 and he was like 18. and she
was like I wouldn't leave the man alone
you know what I mean like my mom was
like I'm not gonna you can't date him
and she was like I have to be with him
you know and they that was like the
reason that she became who she is
whatever but they
had a terrible they were too young and
too rich and too toxic and faced with
too much whatever it was not gonna
survive whatever
when we leave look up shares eulogy for
sunny
bawling crying I watched that all the
time I might watch it today
it's so beautiful the way that that
woman is so smart and she the way that
she talks about people is a way that she
she meets you here you know what I mean
I'm sound I sound crazy no you don't I'm
right there with I know I know there are
people that would not meet you here you
know what I mean like Christina Aguilera
is not gonna make me here I don't think
so either I hate when people say I heard
so and so is mean I heard Beyonce's mean
I don't give a I want her to sing
I don't want to get many pennies with
Beyonce I heard Jennifer Lopez as me it
was mean to someone at sex I was mean to
someone at sex they were mean to me also
it's like we don't know what these women
have been through and what they need to
do and how they need to like get what
they need done done like I know that
Nicki Minaj and her like whatever series
she had terrible she was really mean but
really mean but it's like
I don't know I know a couple hotels
she's banned from in Miami oh oh okay
she's so rude that's cool and you know
what she's still one of the best rappers
of all time sorry sorry I just I won't
see her at the hotel though I guess not
until I see her I did see her in concert
actually she opened for Britney Spears
in 2000
10 from Fatale tour no what chore
circus
it was when the Pussycat Dolls couldn't
okay
um best favorite era of Brittany Onyx
tour
why is that interesting I don't know I
think it's because
I remember I just remembered so clearly
God my Brittany Jean is tacky oh my
God she was like that satin
booty shorts with the Ruffles and the
pink satin vest with like her hand
gloves and she's like no but like no it
looks like it looks like she was
weightlifting like those times you know
what I mean like when the golfers are
like don't get used to the gloves they
might hurt your golf game you know what
I mean but um I think that was like the
last time that we saw her enjoy herself
yes like really enjoy herself where
um I did it didn't look like work and
also she masturbated on stage the touch
of my hand that song is so important
it's so important we really don't we we
don't understand what she did for our
sexuality I completely if American Girl
and Bernice Pierce masturbating on stage
did a lot for me do you have a favorite
album Britney album yeah it's probably
Britney
thank you it really actually really
relieved that you said that that was the
one do you have a favorite moment that
turned you into a super fan for me it
was Slave for You performance at the
VMAs with the snake no no no mine for me
was the
um amas 2001 when she did oops I did it
again and the secret yeah okay that was
probably it for me or no I think it was
watching her interviews and she snorted
I would watch like her interviews when
she still had glasses on she's just like
the rest of us she's and I'm a big
snorter
I don't know I'm like I'm sad that I
said that I'm a big sorter but I I
watched her and she was so I remember
um seeing her on MTV and she was doing
Mall shows and it wasn't even on an
elevated surface she was eye level wow
that's so sweet I love that I remember
MTV Diaries uh
um you think you know you have no idea
Christina Aguilera fighter
um for that one and
Mandy no 98 Degrees do you remember the
Christina Aguilera Kelly Osborne rivalry
there was yes it was I hated a little
bit about Lee yeah yes that's my girl
are you joking that was incredible I
know I am always gonna be team Kelly
was that
Kelly is a complicated girl but you know
what I look at her parents I said
she's doing the best chicken it is what
it is doing the best you can those
parents Ozzy Osbourne is the man that
she's doing the best she can I think she
turned out the best possible way they're
weird they're funny and they're
they're they're like the osbornes to me
that TV show was as funny as Seinfeld
like it was so funny and honest and real
and it wasn't even that they were like
famous wacky people they were just very
much themselves and weird and funny
I think the reality show that I remember
the most growing up
the most was probably I wasn't allowed
to watch MTV till I was like 15. whoa so
I would sneak watching the real world
and the first real world that I saw was
real World Las Vegas
with the pregnancy scare yes that was an
incredible tough great season incredible
time and but honestly I think about it
putting cameras even for Jersey Shore
cameras and people's bedrooms and us
having watching them is crazy so
good but you know what's so good so sad
is like I think I think I was watching
an episode of married Married at First
Sight oh my God and trishelle was in one
of the episodes yeah she's like the
friend of one of the guys on there and
she was just and I'm like sure surely
you're such a star like Michelle go back
to Vegas to Vegas was it Danny mayor oh
I don't remember the guy I remember one
of the girls that she was like a go-go
dancer and that was the first time I
heard the term gogo dancer and I I
thought that was my dream to go go dance
in the club you do look like you
probably just that is the nicest
thing anybody's ever thought you would
ask her I honestly when I think about
that era too there is this teen people
rest in peace teen people spread that I
remember I had on my table as I was
sneaking watching real World Las Vegas
and I had my finger on last last um last
Channel you know when your parents would
come in you go last Channel
and I was reading this it's like a vivid
memory in my home where I grew up it's a
spread open and said the seven blondes
who run
2000 2003 or something seven blondes who
run Hollywood and it was Britney Spears
Christina Aguilera Jessica Simpson Mandy
Moore thank you God
the Olsen twins
and Willa Ford will afford how crazy
that I will never forget those seven
because I was absorbed the way that I
was like like I was obsessed with it and
I wanted to be I wanted to be Mandy
Moore so bad I wanted him to miss me
like candy I wanted a yellow buggy I
wanted the hair flip I wanted it all a
room of my own where I could do my
Disney music video are you kidding you
know what I mean oh Willa Willa Ford
Willa Nick Carter's
that's right wait a second you guys
never got into like um any of the VH1
reality shows argument like shot at love
with Tila Tequila are you kidding me the
first bisexual reality dating show and
Sheila tequila has me blocked on all
platforms you want to talk about Nazis
[Music]
you know Tila Tequila now is very
Evangelical it's she's taking a turn
that I have tried to step away from do
you know that when I just said you want
to talk about an office you or that Tick
Tock sound that's Mariah Carey nobody
wants to talk about 911 though that's
like yeah
anyway at Tila Tequila what were the
other ones there was oh um uh the guy
from Poison uh Brett Michaels um Flavor
Flav Flavor Flav oh they were all of
those girls were stars School Charm
School
um
the the uh incredible clip where she's
Monique is renaming people away from
their Flavor of Love names and she says
she goes what's your name baby she goes
Safari she goes and then we're gonna
leave that ugly name behind remember
we're we're gonna name what's your real
name she goes
Safari that's one of my favorite
favorite clips of all time or when in
Flavor of Love Hot says everyone tells
me I look like Beyonce and I love New
York goes Beyonce she looks at the zoo's
camera she goes Beyonce I'm so sorry
baby that is funny and she goes you look
like Luther Vandross
my actual birth mother I think the woman
who raised me the most is lorianne
Gibson on making the band three diddy
you don't think I go
I love that Making the Band take her
make her go home Audrey make her go home
with Andrea yeah
I can't pass the job actually don't
think about those boys dude my friend
named her daughter Andrea after Andrea
because it had the U after it right I
would tell my friend to lie about that
babies named after what do you
baby you know who you're named after
what are you talking about babe Tuffy
how was Japan it was great you just got
back I just got back yeah did it change
your life Coachella absolutely I was
just telling Emily well this is my
assistant Emily
um my friend and uh I'm like a diagnosed
Insomniac and for some reason when I
went rock and roll babe there's a lot of
things to see on the internet I know
it's too fun out there
um I was not saving I think I would
sleep every day at like 6 a.m and then
I'd wake up at like one like I would
tell my team like please don't schedule
anything before one because like I'm
that's when I wake up you know and it
was driving me crazy too because I'm
obsessed with productivity and I feel
like I was missing out on so much and
then by the time that you're already
like in the mood to start like working
it's like
what 4 P.M it sucks
I went to Japan I was falling asleep
every night at 8pm oh you were speaking
about this phenomenon I tell everybody
you go One Direction and it's always to
Asia and you will sleep the most you
have ever had and it's like the kind of
deep Slumber that you will never have
again as even like the first day that
you're back here I don't know what it is
but I think there is something about
like the time zones that either allow
for it because I have my friend from New
York just went with me to the
Philippines right around the same time
you were in Japan and same type she
she's up at three in the morning at the
gym such a productivity Queen she
planned her own platinum wedding like
one of those like just inside the energy
Type A and she never gets more than like
three hours a night of sleep and she
feels fine on three hours so when we're
resting in Asia when we went to the
Philippines she was getting a full eight
hours no no I've never slept like this
and
I think it's also because I felt safe I
feel safe in my home all the time but
it's different it was like different I
felt like welcome and safe I can't
explain it there's a peace in Asia that
I cannot explain it's like a piece and
like a
like an accepted I can't explain it it's
like a I don't know but I was just like
walking around I had the time in my life
I never worried about my safety I mean
Japan like amazing my antidepressant is
illegal there right I know if you want
to take your antidepressant you have to
register it it's insane especially
because Wellbutrin Wellbutrin for Life
Lexapro
life is more exciting when there are
peaches involved and that's why we're
brought to you by simply Spike Peach
from the makers of Simply Spike lemonade
simply Spike Peach is now available 21
and over only contains alcohol
what I really love about these simply
spiked drinks is that they use real
fruit juice
um all flavors of Simply spiked are
crafted with five percent ABV and five
percent real fruit juice squeezed then
concentrated this spring simply spiked
as introducing a flavor that fans have
been asking for since day one simply
Spike Peach you guys it's been really
warm in La lately and um I went to the
beach over the weekend and I cracked
open one of these simply spiked drinks
and they are so good did you know that
there's real fruit juice in it so
refreshing you guys summer's coming up
go grab you
um a variety pack they have signature
Peach strawberry peach kiwi Peach and
mango peach go to drinksimplyspike.com
trash Tuesday to find out how to get
your hands on new simply Spike Peach
that's
drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday this
is flavored beer naturally flavored with
other natural flavors simply Spike Co
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply spiked as a trademark
of the Simply Orange Juice company
cool I'm always a victim of this that
try it for free for 30 days just enough
time to try it and then come I
completely forget about it in fact over
80 percent of people have subscriptions
they forget about you could be wasting
money and not even realizing it rocket
money helps you find those forgotten
subscriptions and you can stop paying
for ones you don't use for example I
think I had like an insect finder on
there for three years without knowing it
and I had an anime app a streaming app
that I didn't know I had for five years
because my niece downloaded it onto my
phone this is where rocket money is
really valuable it helps you find these
subscriptions and cancel it pocket money
is a personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place
rocket money will quickly and easily
find your subscriptions for you and for
any you don't want to pay for anymore
just hit cancel and Rocket money will
cancel it for you it's that easy rocket
money also helps you manage all of your
finances in one place and automatically
categorizes your expenses so you can
easily track your budget in real time
and also get alerted if anything looks
off over 3 million people have used
rocket money saving the average person
up to seven hundred and twenty dollars a
year stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
when I came back I fell asleep at 8pm
and for the when I came back and when I
um when I came back I've been falling
asleep at eight and waking up at six I'm
having the time of my life but tomorrow
I go to Coachella I know it's gonna go
to it's over it's over guys well I
so I'm extremely under slept because
I've been running off at two hours of
sleep because as soon as I got back here
like today I only slept for two hours
last night you napped you just sleep
your nap yeah I napped and I like I miss
my Asian sleep like I cannot for the
life of me get my back together let
me caught my Asian Slumber and then I'm
gonna have to look at people and explain
but you know what when they go there or
if they go there they'll understand
insane me and my friend we went and we
were like two bugs in a rug
which is a disgusting term I look at my
rug sometimes like but I like literally
so cozy I felt swaddled by your hands
swaddled like a baby I understand to
Julie did you eat anything amazing I
made I ate everything I'm an explorative
eater
my friend was not like I'm an
adventurous eater like if you gave me
bark with hummus on it I would eat it
and if you told me it was good I'm like
I want good stuff you know what I mean
so I'll eat something I don't like
things that are super super fishy but
I'll only know if it's super fishy if I
eat it right God you know what I mean
well super super fishy would just kind
of
maybe not be as like fresh yeah exactly
or like they eat like raw squid and that
gelatin and I ate it be like not though
oh yeah yes I do
yes I do you're the real world
sometimes when he's like a like um let's
say you're cheer tin sometimes it
depends I don't know what it depends on
but sometimes I do and sometimes I don't
okay so well not who is either you like
it or you don't there's no like Middle
Ground yeah because it's slimy
but it is so um I don't know it is a
comfort food but same kind of for me
like it took me a while to get to natto
but when I got there I got there when
you got there yeah yeah the train
yeah once you like something but as I
get older I can feel myself getting
pickier and pickier like I I
I've never been somebody who like when
somebody says like oh but it's the
texture I'm like I don't get that I
don't understand what you're talking
about cooked Peppers freak me out now
and I've never been and they're so sweet
and there's all nine of peppers like red
green and yellow because that makes
you gassy as I I completely stay
awake because it lights me up though
that yes I love Peppers but like green
like just bell peppers oh my God I'm
double down in pain that is some of
those gaseous food ever that's delicious
as I get older I get gas here me too
what's going on
she think you know what I mean this is
an HOA issue it is I want you to do that
who told you to do that remember you
could just like eat a just massive meal
before going out to the club and not
even think twice about it do you
remember drinking oh my God I I have two
glasses of wine and I'm like I'm the
most rock and roll that's ever
thank you I'm the most rocked and but
then the next day
I'm like I'm like the you know when
Robin Hood is like the fox and he's
pretending to be like a beggar and he
has like the glasses on you know what
I'm talking about in Robin Hood yes
that's what I feel like I'm sorry all I
could think about is like Robin Hood Men
in Tights I'm like oh so good so good so
good so now I'm talking about the end of
the real the animation oh the anime the
the fox yes yes you know what I mean
um before we finish up here I want to
talk to you about finishing trusting
well not yet before trusting your gut
because you had a post recently on
Instagram yeah how you and I had really
related to this and I wanted to talk
more about it
you maybe stop trusting your guy or you
were following people who weren't
trusting their gut and then you like can
you talk to you about what that
experience was do you know what got in
your way from being able to trust your
gut and how did you be able to get that
skill back I mean have you ever heard
um me being attracted to someone is
already a red flag
like you don't trust your type yeah you
know what I mean like it's I I think I
think for me I
um I believe I believe when you tell me
something so if you tell me that you
want what's best for me I believe you
but what I've realized is as time went
on with some friends in my life or
people they did not expect me to do well
they always expected to do better than
me and they liked it that way
so I realized as time went on that
um I wasn't following their good wishes
I was following or I was following
someone who resented me
or somebody who looked at me and saw
dollar signs so but these are people
that
listen a lot of people meet my mom a lot
of people don't come and eat with me you
know what I mean like these are people
that I would take on family vacations I
mean these are people who knew my family
intimate intimately you know what I mean
and I treated people like family and I
loved them and I feel like they made me
doubt myself so much and even even
relationships where I'm like I
I did I did everything right like I or
I'm not even right but like I did the
best that I could and I know for a fact
that it's more than enough
and this person still me over and
the same with friends and same with
business or whatever so now when I talk
about intuition and everything they
me over
if it was in a relationship it's for
fear and it's trauma right and I don't
want to pay for your grandfather
did to your dad all right I don't want
to do that anymore
how is it that somewhere in the past one
man didn't hug his son and now pay for
it and then when it's like with business
and stuff it's greed and greed comes
from a lot of issues and something out
and jealousy comes from you know all all
these these are all secondary emotions
right
and so I'm following around these people
who can't even speak to their feelings
or tell me the truth about who they are
and I promise you I'm the kind of
that like if you sat down with me and
you're like listen I'm jealous and any
time away
I would be like I get it I
respect that you know what I mean like I
love you and I want to be your friend
and you know my life isn't roses
either I'm not Nicole Kidman
over here you know what I mean
uh you know I'm I'm Naomi Watts and I'm
just kidding but I I feel like the I
just like the sharing of it you know
what I mean but these are also people
who saw me really from like the bottom
like these are people that like I would
run to when I needed somebody and
looking back they liked it and I guess I
didn't know how to be my friend anymore
when things were going well we all we
knew how to be my friend this is a very
common phenomenon that I've heard a lot
and like I've experienced as well black
it is a it is a pandemic whack
it's people that like when you
are having problems and it's it's the
opposite of a fair weather friend I
don't know what to call it yeah you're
right and it is also it's interesting
because I've extracted a lot of value
from people like that because they have
really helped me when I'm low but that
was never worth it like knowing that
that that was how they did well or I
don't know do you know what I'm saying
oh I absolutely know what you're saying
it it because you are
you are providing them this type of like
currency that they need like in the same
way like narcissistic Supply works you
are like by you being below them for
however many years you were below them
is is supplying them with something that
they need for themselves right and when
that's no longer there you are of no use
to them anymore because that Supply is
not there yeah like so it's almost like
what you you're you having problems they
don't really like you they like the way
it makes them feel yeah exactly oh
that's like a Munchausen thing totally
um I have a family member that my mom's
beefing with right now for that same
exact reason as soon as I started as
soon as she saw my mom's daughters doing
well she could yeah she was just like
nope and and we don't even have a
relationship anymore and before that she
was the same family member that would
never miss a birthday of mine always
give me money always just be like really
like noting anymore but I don't and now
it's just work kind of in this even
playing field because she makes good
money and now I treat her like an equal
she cannot stand it she cannot bear to
even look at me you took away her
favorite role right this is my new thing
right I'm only looking for equals in my
life I want equals I don't want you
lower I don't want you higher I want
equals I want to validate my experience
with other equals like that is that's
what's right that's what I'm looking for
I don't really need equals I just want
some I just want to be around people who
which here we cheer each other on right
you could work you could be a cashier at
the supermarket and you come to me and
you tell me you made manager I want to
go out and pop bottles but I can be
equals what that person as long as it
motion it's yes because
I I what sucks about the thing that
you're saying what I related to the most
was like when you do put trust in people
like that
you suddenly like your gut gets whacked
out like I for so long realized oh I
wasn't even following my gut or trusting
my intuition because I was trusting in
other people and this is my issue right
like I take responsibility that I went
go down past with other people but it's
nice for me recently to step more into
the role of checking in with myself what
do I really feel what do I need yeah
it's the difference between is it
anxiety or is it intuition is it
overthinking or is it my gut and that's
really hard and sometimes your
gut is not available for you in the
moment and you can dig as deep as you
want and you know like at least for me
just like having been like just having
like a really like shitty child and
whatnot like I I was just talking to ask
her about this like I can't be present
sometimes if I'm just surviving the
moment I don't have access to my gut if
I'm going everywhere to take care of you
not right it's just getting through the
moment like my gut will show up later on
but I'm like I need it right now
tell me what I'm supposed to do but I
cannot for the like with Pinocchio
we just talked about this yeah that's
your body taking over
when that like moment of like um
forgetting something or putting it away
or that moment of fear or mistrust
like is that your intuition telling you
like it's bad from or me like forgetting
my body took care of me and helped me
forget that because it was scary right
and for you it traumatizes you in a way
where like if you were ever faced with
that your body's like this is familiar
let me take care of this right we just
talked about that yeah
were we recording when we were talking
about the donkeys in Pinocchio
Pinocchio and the donkeys it's scary and
it scared a lot of children you know
what I mean so scary
I'm sorry I got excited and I cut you
off no you didn't we were in a circle it
was amazing yeah no but yeah I think
intuition is is the part of you that um
wants you to wants you to do well and
sometimes that's also when you overthink
and it's negative self-talk it's like
what if this goes bad what if you fail
and I feel like that's the part of you
that also loves you so much that it
doesn't want to see you suffer so it's
better if you just stay home and you
don't go you know what I mean it's
better if you don't try because you
could fail and you have to look at that
part and be like I love you I know you
don't need to feel sad but I have to do
this you know what I mean that's how I
feel often like I really do have to sit
down and like there's a part of me that
is like a runner I run from
uncomfortable things like in the past
fight or so flight when like my gut can
sometimes tell me when my body takes
over it's like get out of there but if I
stop and think I'm like oh this could be
an opportunity for someone to kind of
put a mirror up to me and really like oh
like what I've done wrong how can I
improve and the choice to actually say
okay like I'm gonna hate this but I need
to hear it and is is you know
what I mean like it's difficult
hard that mirror is a sometimes I
say uncle sometimes I'm like no I'm cool
don't be tapping out tapping out or like
I put it down and go no no no no no yeah
absolutely yeah that mirror is a
piece of where you have to
um relationships or mirrors like every
time I will think I'm the coolest girl I
like a guy and I'm like there's some
unresolved drama you know what I mean
why am I checking him from my friend's
yoga page why am I taking history he's a
he has a job you know what I mean like
who the is this you know what I
mean like the the there's parts of the
mirror that go with everything or like
my anger
I there's so much of my career where I'm
just like I cannot do things so that my
my the people that have wronged me will
see it and feel bad I cannot dedicate my
success to that because then it's not
even for me and it'll never be enough
but boy does it feel good sometimes oh
my God it's my I could jack off too but
same under six seconds that is my
favorite flashlight
I'm not anti those vibes I'm Pro those
vibes but here's something that I'll
admit that's really difficult for me is
um I sometimes even on podcasts I take
pride in saying like oh I was left
behind jealousy I'm no longer a jealous
person because or for whatever reason I
feel cool saying I'm no longer the
jealous girl but for every boy that I
dated since my breakup even people like
I don't necessarily see myself with long
term the Intel that I have done and I
mean hours and hours pages of pages like
you you don't think I know his like
third cousin from Virginia you're wrong
and happy graduation
and and and some and I will never this
person will never ever know they can
look at me and be like khalila she is so
securely attached if not if anything
maybe even slightly avoided and I'm like
no I'm the most anxious person
attached I I know but like I do this and
I'm like how embarrassing it is that I'm
38. and I have this deep burning I am
there's no shame and embarrassment in
this because the fact that you're a
doctor the fact that you girls do this I
do this this is biological this is not
us this is who this is not our fault
that we do this I'm not taking
responsibility men are Hunters we are
gatherers we're Gathering we're
gathering information we can no longer
gather berries no I you're correct
because this is how apparently this is
why women love um like Dr pimple popper
stuff and men are like ripples by it
absolutely because of we have I guess
been grooming our partners and our
children through like out like the
history of time so like 95 I think or
something really really high statistic
of um people that watch Dr pimple pop
are all women because we like
groom and we like to gather and we like
to do these things but I wanted to ask
you guys
um that there's this study that
basically says that when men look at
idealized photos of women they can
become less attracted to their partner
versus women who can look at the same
idealized photos of men and not be any
less satisfied with their partner and so
it's like for the longest time I was
just like oh I'm secure I don't care if
he likes a another woman's picture on
Instagram but I'm like now that I I read
this I'm like oh I was wrong
I think men are so stupid that they
think that is real ah it's like
insane to me that like they will see
that first of all like even I was just
talking about this with one of my
friends he was like I'm like who is that
and he's like oh this girl I follow and
I'm like does she follow you back and
he's like no and I'm like
I'm like have a little prize
ew and he's like I don't care and I'm
like you care you care
you know what I mean like kill me but I
feel like with men too it's like it's
just a different brain
and I truly like if we watch celebrity
stuff or whatever like he's hot I would
I wonder if I would ever hook up with
him if I was in a room with him or I got
the chance whatever
I think men truly believe that they
could emrata I think they
really do why who they though because
this came up earlier in this
conversation where the guy thought you
were hitting on him because you hugged
him why have I had nice long
conversations with men in my business
and then I later hear oh so-and-so said
he could you if you wanted to I'm
like because I talked to him why why do
they think that they can why why well I
think you know brain development in that
home is still a mystery and
maybe wait they differentiate a little
later boys do sexually right like
everything is a girl until the cell like
differentiates yeah and two so maybe
they're a little bit later I think I
think men live in have they make fun of
women but nobody has more hot girl
delusion than men yes nobody has more
hot mental what's that saying
um when you're when you feel imposter
syndrome pretend you're a white mediocre
man
are you kidding me Michelle
Robinson Obama said that that she's met
a lot of these people who are CEOs and
run and run these huge companies and
they're not very smart men but they just
think that they are there's a quote that
like 80 of the job is just showing up I
tell it to myself all the time when I'm
like man I'm tired but 80 is
just showing up and I think that they
they really truly believe
that they have big dicks and they have
great personalities and their hair is
full they really do they believe it and
you know what and if not they're like
it I'll just go to turkey turkey
good for you go back okay so I I just
went down a rabbit hole of um men
getting all the Fue hair transplants in
turkey and like you see like a plain
full can I tell you something about that
why are you as a man posting all of your
little scabs on Tick Tock don't take me
through that Journey wait I didn't do
the same what the is wrong with you
why he's like oh so this is day three
I'm like this put it away
this is them shampooing their scabs off
what the is wrong what the is
wrong with you put it away why are you
as a man blogging vlogging your hair
transplant put it away I don't need to
see that
bring my friend dason says something
bring back shame and bring back Secrets
I believe in that that I can stand by I
think there is like a level of shame we
ought to bring back just universally and
then there's shampooing and he's like ah
stop it
why are you like this oh my God
nuts it drives me nuts at things that
men will do I lately have been seeing a
lot of like and I know this is just me
being a whatever and I don't know
I have a problem but it's projecting in
some form but I've been seeing guys I
know like because I follow a lot of hot
girls so I'm part of the problem but
because you are hot girl thank you and
it's studying I've been doing my work my
job
um
and I will see guys we know liking
and it just makes me so sick and sad I'm
just like what are you what are you
doing do you know that we can see you
what it is is are you is this a move I
have to hold the mic like this do you
think that she's gonna look and see
through all the guys that like it I
don't know oh my God this guy this guy
was at the comedy seller I should follow
him back let me message him no but it's
never gonna happen Brian oh he's
Brian come on Brian get it together but
people still name their kids Brian
absolutely they do they do don't they
absolutely they do hi Daniel to Brian
how was it well they're not together
anymore you know my the the the guy who
um
um sexually assaulted me Brian oh
yeah what all Brian I'm like
man and I look at my brother and
I'm like
when the gender War I'll miss you but
you're a good you're a good dude okay I
have my last question which is so I have
a question for you great I'm okay this
is so cheesy but I have this belief that
successful people are successful because
they have a why deep inside them they
they have a purpose what is your why and
your purpose like what do you make
people laugh share Who You Are
do you have that do you know what that
is like what are you out here getting
out of bed making the videos sharing
with the world what's your why for all
that I think one of it is
um I mean I'm first generation to an
immigrant family so it's like Pride
somebody the day was like are you a
capitalist I'm like I have to be what
are you talking about
um
I think it's one it's like I really want
my family to be proud of me but they
already are like I could literally be
the best newspaper tosser in town and
I'm gonna be like
you know so they don't ask a lot of me
they just want me to be okay and I think
a lot of people don't understand that
that like your parents just want you to
be okay like they don't need that much
from you alas you'll see me on the cover
of Forbes
um I think that's one two I want to show
people
there was a long time in history or
being
a was really profitable
and I think a big part of me wants to
show people how being nice and funny is
so easy and it works you know what I
mean and then three
I think it probably like the biggest one
is that I know I can do it so I want to
do it and I think I deserve to do what I
want to do I know I can do it like there
are people who
um
think like if I got the opportunity I
don't I hope I don't it up and for
me it's different I'm like how can I get
this opportunity because I I can do this
I know what I mean kill it and I'll kill
it yeah I know that so there are lots of
places in my life where I'm not
confident you know like of course you
know
um I was telling people today I have
that one nipple hair no matter if you
shave your nipples once that's all you
have is one she's she makes the other
ones look puny it's like Godzilla versus
baby goats all right it's just one and
then
um like there's a bunch of stuff you
know what I mean like because Esther and
I are like notorious hairy nipple baby
I'm like the way guys I take it all my
father's Brazilian I have Portuguese
blood my pubes are like Bermuda shorts
if I let them all right let's not you're
in good company like my Knuckles if I
let them they go no my toes Robin
Williams is nice
may your rest in peace I love Robin but
like uh I think I think that's one thing
for me that I'm just like
there was so long that people convinced
me that I couldn't do it or I couldn't
do it without them or they convinced me
that it was embarrassing but now that I
know that I can do it why won't I why
wouldn't I want to do all of it I'd
rather try and embarrass myself than
ever look at somebody I was watching
this like inside the Actors Studio with
Jay Leno I didn't know it was at Pace
University but basically at the end of
this presentation when they talk about
you know like the milestones in this
person's career you ask the audience
questions and they're all in drama right
they're all like drama students and this
one kid was like how do I get to do what
you want to do and Jay Leno was like I'm
used to watch this as like a kid you
know but I remember I remember what I
was wearing when I was watching this he
said be honest with me he's like stand
up and the kid stands up he's like be
honest with me do you think that you
could do my job better than me and the
guy's like
I don't know you know like I don't know
we're different he's like if you don't
think you can do your job better than me
then you won't get my job because why
would you get my job if you're not
better than me and the guy was like okay
yeah I could do your job better than you
and he was like and that's how you'll
know you make it and then so and if you
always keep that you'll keep going so
while I look at people I mean I'm not
looking at Meryl Streep and being like
amateur no but I look at people and I
and I see opportunities that I want and
I know that I could do it better and
that's it doesn't mean the person
just means I'm better no it just means
that I want I want that and if I
continue thinking that way
and the gratification of working really
hard for something and getting it is
really wonderful and I want that for
everybody you know whether it be
a financial goal a personal goal you
know whatever it is maybe it's saving up
your money so you can go to Thailand
like like being on that plane like right
now I feel like I'm on that plane you
know what I mean I'm just trying to get
over there and I and I'm enjoying it so
I'm so inspired I love you
I am that's a beautiful why thank you
why I now makes me question my own wife
my mother's why was not for my kids when
she didn't have kids
right so give yourself some Grace you
know yeah
my only why is like to make enough money
so I can get Asian Slumber twice a year
I think I'm an Asian Lumber and I said
is there a is there a wood is there a
wood there is so our the type of lumber
that we export there's mahogany oh my
God there's Nara we have a lot of rubber
trees that kind of lumber yeah yeah I'm
winning that sap baby yeah
deforestations is real well my friend
was on a debate team and they were
talking about euthanasia
and she was like what do teens in Asia
have anything to do with this it was so
crazy but yeah that's it I want to end
with
um
um what we started with and but I don't
think we were recording no which is like
is there
um is
we're talking about Kink King gaming
yeah all of these things and you know my
belief is that your king and whatever it
is that gets you off is in a completely
different compartment in your brain than
your morality your values and like who
your character is a person like I don't
think one touches the other so it's like
for instance like my example is always
like you know I was diddled as a kid
like by you know a family member say for
instance but like my my Kink or I'm
saying I'm not opposed to age play like
because that's that's weird when
no I'm not not age play but I'm not
opposed to whatever role play Let's
suppose like if there is like like you
know Melody rapey whatever like it
doesn't it that part of my brain doesn't
connect to the other part of my brain
it's always in the spirit of play but
you're saying you think sometimes
there's a through line I think people
sometimes use the excuse of Kink when it
is not a kink I mean I was
I'm gonna bring up communism but I think
a lot of people like in Miami for
example there's a lot of Latin American
Trauma from surrounding islands and
countries like there's a reason there's
a lot of Haitian people there's a reason
there's a lot of Cuban people there's a
reason there's a lot of Venezuelan
people and these dictators use the veil
of Communism so now if you if they hear
the word communism or socialism they
think about the homes that they had to
leave because of this you know what I
mean it's really
dictatorship whatever you know what I
mean and I feel like we people use a lot
of blanket terms to kind of lure people
in then I feel like we used
TW
um Army Hammer as like he said that like
um like like an aggressive like really
rough sex was like his Kink but it
turned out that he got off on seeing
women in terrible pain dude and that's
and the BDSM Community we talked about
came out and was like that is not a kink
because the whole BDSM Community
remember I said remember I said our
community and I'm like I'm talking for
them I'm not in the BDSM Community
literally rubbing noses is a foreplay
for me
but like
um they said uh you know like the whole
thing about BDSM is consent that's safe
words are right an Army Hammer would say
uh like this these women would come out
and be like I would say our safe word
and he would put his hand over my mouth
so they yeah the word Kink to me is like
I had one boyfriend that he had like a
mommy Kink so I would talk to him in
baby voice
and I didn't like it but he loved it he
loved it you know what I mean and so
that's I think that's like a kink and I
don't think it has anything I don't
think he wants to his mom you know
what I mean right seeing women in pain
and making them uncomfortable
that's not a starting thing like a king
is like I can't like um I'm I'm I'm
sending it to meds from Germany hello
I'm new here I don't know anybody or
like you know what I mean like well yeah
go to the bar and you're like what do
you do I could never do that
dude my ex and I yeah we would do role
play and he would be like an aristocrat
and I would be a Shoemaker
no I'm talking about like meet me at the
bar and like I'm I'm I'm a mistress if
my husband came up to me and was like
Hey girl I'll be like you're on the
battery
you know what I mean so what did you
like about her you and my husband
be like it's you but whatever
um I think I I think when it comes to
role play and stuff like that like
that's so fun I my um my friend was
talking to me about how she did one
where it was um like the the plumber and
the and the housewife like that's fun
you know what I mean but if it's like
hey can you cut off a piece of your
thigh and watch me eat it like what if
what if what if I was a shoe cobbler and
you were the Aristocrat like I would
that's that's different or like
even like sub and you want to put a dog
collar on me that's cool I really like
being treated like a dog it both
sexually and plutonically
I want you to hug more
my Kink is being loved in return and and
monogamy that's my special yeah because
you get intimacy boners yeah what's
wrong with missionary oh my God
missionary is my favorite event in China
you cannot I'm sorry there's a reason
why it is like it is the go-to because I
you know like when you're those
missionaries have something going they
were on they did like you know when
you're younger and you take pride and
you're like yeah we did it this way in
that way in that way I want to keep my
legs on the bed bro thank you my
background girl get the out of my
house you want my what the
no oh can we do the sexy otter get the
out of my house I'll see myself out
no I I agree let's keep it simple and
also in relationships I love when you
get to the place where you're just like
what are you doing after doggy I get on
top you're mixing up the order
you know what we do here come on what
are you talking about you know but at
the end of the day like sex is so
intimate and like the idea of like
role-playing should be fun and BDSM and
like all that stuff the whole point of
all of this of existing it should be fun
some parts suck yeah some parts
suck but healing is fun too you
know like doing the hot cups and
meditation and going to a
infrared sauna that's rock and roll I
love healing yoga opening my hips
Pilates amazing you know doing drugs
rock and roll we love healing you know
what I mean but the whole point is like
to have a good time and if at any point
during sex I'm like this is scary I
don't want to do this I'm not having
good time I'm drier than a
you know what I mean his belly isn't
hitting my
I I don't then I'm then I'm not in for
it and if a vibrant makes me do it
yeah you're right you're right we don't
need you there's a there's a there's a
an inventor somewhere that made that for
me who am I to insult them by not using
their technology you're right but what
if that you know relegates your fingers
and you know deems amuseless you can no
longer come from your own hands that's
my biggest fear what a time to be alive
you always have access to an outlet
what a time and all they figured out
their voltages so internationally
because before you'd have to travel to
different countries you'd have to bring
the adapter yeah because it would be
like 110 and 220 and if you would were
to plug it in the wrong it would just
explode right like you know your
vibrators your speakers
no it's not like that yeah off the
Mayflower pilgrim
I don't get it I'll be honest I do
travel with tube I always have a backup
vibrator if I don't travel the vibrator
I Postmates one
well that's so smart I have a lot of
stress
Mommy needs her de-stressor is it ever
awkward when the guy brings it and he
knows what he's bringing here I look at
the ground I go thanks so much
um Tuffy thank you so much for being the
most I have a question for you before I
go yes
do you pay for those Paparazzi shots I
think they're incredible oh
I don't pay because they're my fiance
and he's great at it and if you ever
want it's incredible I was like dude
these people on her dick hole they are
non-stop let the woman walk her dog
they are incredible please let if you
ever wanna get some he's very good
absolutely yes very good yeah watching
me from afarland and he's free I'll pay
him you've got your friends if you don't
pay your friends who will you're not
paying Dave is the best yeah he really
is I love him are you gonna take his
last name I already did on Instagram
okay yeah his name is Dave King yeah
he's your king yeah it's incredible
wonderly pray for something like that I
know it's I with the last scene pavitsky
my whole life I really deserve this
Esther King sounds massive too
like huge like it has like Maryland row
energy oh my God I love you that coming
from you is very meaningful did you hear
what Bobby said on tigerbelly on our
podcast he was like it's that
Esther took Dave's name she shouldn't be
allowed unless
um they get married oh well I need the
clip I'll send you the clip oh wow I
guess he doesn't make the rules if he's
mad too I don't care it's a better name
it's a Rebrand wait so you're not
married you took his name regardless you
just you just had a name change we've
been together for 10 years I only
changed it online I didn't do anything I
didn't do any paperwork how long ago was
his bachelor party it was five years ago
we might get married this fall there's
actually been talks we have like there
might be a wedding we've been at a
standstill for a while you just came
home one day and you're like I changed
my name you're so you're beyond iconic
what if I was just like taffy Momoa
why not
supposed to stop you I mean like legally
legal team
then I don't think he can and if I would
change my that's I talk about this in my
stand-up I'm like ladies if you like a
guy just change your name take the name
show them you're serious dude I came in
you know that's her party was five
years ago the sun has gone around the
planet five times since he celebrated
his Bat and I showed up
uninvited that almost
slowed things down I as well why did you
see that
I thought he would like it I thought it
was surprising him and it was going to
be fun and he it wasn't have you ever
met a man
imagine if I was on my bachelorette and
my dude showed up all the women would
start audibly booing where can people I
mean at hello teffy would you where else
are we finding you these days I always
say in your tree thank you so much and
um yeah hella Heavy Across the world
across all across all borders we love
her we need her for her she's a part of
the trash Tuesday family
she is going to open a school one day I
will be the first student to sign up
Tuffy thank you so much and we will see
you guys next week with a brand new
episode you're welcome bye guys
thank you